it's good to be in a city I was just not
in a city I was doing a show in a small
town in Texas called Tex Arcana yeah and
I'm sure there are wonderful people in
Texarkana none of them came to the show
I don't want to say the crowd was dumb
but they had a magician open up the show
and they booed him yeah after every
trick they're just like bird get off the
stage and he wasn't even a bad magician
they were just afraid of magic he didn't
he scared them after every trick they're
like ah come on quit messing around them
handkerchiefs buddy like they had no
idea has we keep pulling all that at a1
top hat that ain't possible one more
trick they were gonna kill him and I'm a
peaceful guy but I was rooting for it
just so I could have gone to the trial
and seen this guy defend himself like
look your honor
you got to understand a little something
okay I've never opened fire against
another individual but he took a
newspaper cut it up in the back ten
never letter paces and then he puts it
back together like I ain't even been cut
one the devil is the only one strong
enough who can do that and his trick
here the devil will trick you can't
stand Smith cuz now the judge is scared
you know
[Music]
and I love I love living in California
I'm never gonna go surfing I don't want
to get eaten by a shark and a buddy of
mine who surfs every day is like dude
come on
they don't even like how we taste thanks
supposed to help me I don't like how
potato salad tastes but if I'm starving
and there's a bowl of it right in front
of me moving a tenth of the speed that I
can doesn't even know I'm there it's
just hopping up and down like an idiot
why I'm just gonna eat it I'll be like
it wasn't the best meal but no longer
hungry
they don't even like how we taste how do
you think they find out we taste bad
they're not born knowing it they you
know they're just swimming along they
take a bite they're like oh that was not
a seal what was that then they call
their buddies over like hey Gary
dude bite there tell me what that is
cuz that tastes awful
right I am from Texas and I'm Mexican I
know I look like a Jew just stop now all
right let it go and every Mexican family
in Texas we all have that one racist
white uncle
it's amazing that dude who hated
Mexicans but he married one anyway
didn't realize her fertility levels were
just off the charts
he's been with her two years he already
has five kids none of course wins every
Christmas she can't hear him but you
read his mind he's just standing by the
tree he's got that look on his face like
I can't believe Mexican running around
messing up the words the jingle bear
singing silent night in their own damn
lame
but these tamales are pretty good like
that's right he's my uncle I've got he's
so racist if you tell him a racist joke
he doesn't even laugh he's just like I
know
I keep trying to warn everybody about
calm down I being a nerd I'm very
excited for the new Star Wars movies I
can't wait yes but because I'm Mexican
I'm pissed they got to fix one thing
okay the early movies the original ones
were racist to Mexicans and I realized
that watching him again the Jawas the
little things with the glowing eyeballs
who do you think they were they were
Brown they talk fast nobody understood
them how did they make a living they
would collect junk and then fix it and
then sell it back to white people and
what happened when their business was
done all of them hopped in one van and
drove off into the desert fix the Jawa
okay JJ Abrams if you are watching right
now I don't care about Han shooting
first fix the Jawas okay I don't haggle
ah I lost Jawas thank you very much you
guys been awesome